salut tout le monde je suis les odeurs
type angie je suis ici avec mister
géopolitique et théo de ballades mental
et on est dans l'archipel norvégien du
svalbard un mix 300 km du pôle nord et
on a ici pour vous faire découvrir ce
petit bout de territoire qui sert en
fait de laboratoire aux scientifiques du
monde entier pour étudier le dérèglement
climatique
[Musique]
on
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'archipel du svalbard a été découvert
en 1596 par l'explorateur néerlandais
willem barens entre le xviie siècle et
de 18e il a servi de camp de base
internationale pour la chasse à la
baleine et le commerce de peaux ce n'est
qu'au début du xxème que john munro
l'ong ir hommes d'affaires américains
décident d'exploiter les sols et les
montagnes de l'archipel qui sont très
riches en charbon en 1906 il crée la
première société des mines de l'article
et il passe dix ans à investir pour
développer cette petite ville qui
servira de camp de base pour
l'exploitation du charbon qui porte
d'ailleurs son nom non urbaines
on va monter dans une mine désaffectée
tenter d'explorer un peu ce qui ya donc
là ils sont fermées elles sont
condamnées on va essayer de voir quand
même si on veut pas y rentrer c'est un
peu déconseillé d'y aller parce que avec
le temps il ya des risques d'éboulement
et des risques d'effondrement du
bâtiment
donc on va être prudent il faut voir ce
qu'on trouve là c'est parti
[Musique]
chaque année environ 200 mineurs suédois
et norvégiens principalement venez
travailler dans les conditions extrêmes
de lille attirés par la promesse de bons
salaires
[Musique]
alors viens de monter chez pas 200 m de
dénivelé tête
ici il ya 22 millions de tonnes de
charbon qui ont été extraites la couche
charbon ni faire toutes les
installations de les infrastructures
sont des infrastructures minières
c'est juste un passé où il est en fait
on est dans le rouge mais de l'arctique
mais dans un décor qui est pratiquement
intemporel en fait la mine a été fermé
dans les années 80 et on pourrait très
bien être au fin fond du quai du kansas
où vous de l'arkansas dans en 1830 y ait
quelque chose d'un peu surréel quoi moi
là je me verrais bien avec un colt un
petit chapeau bas m l'avait depuis
quelques semaines et avoir traversé un
désert
là on a des banques il ya des sacs de
charbon quelques trucs qui ont été
laissées en l'état ça a pris cher aussi
parce que après 40 ans minimum
d'inoccupation le temps fait son travail
ne sommes pas très stable
visiblement il entreposait bras le
matériel ici plein de pièces métalliques
type rouages pour faire de la
maintenance
on suppose est donc sage est strictement
aucune idée de ce que c'est du coup on
va peut-être évité de le toucher
en tout cas ça a commencé à faire des
belles réactions chimiques à la base
puis en hausse est tout blanc
là en fait à des systèmes de poids c'est
une balance
elle est complètement prises dans la
glace talent et interactif sur la moitié
de l'appareil là encore la touche de la
calculatrice qui son fonctionnement le
tableau électrique voilà françois qu'on
s'assure au sol en fait tu pas fondée on
est sur vidal qui sur des poutres
je crois qu'on vient de trouver vos
traits de la mine la mine 2b qui a été
opérationnelle de 1937 à 1968 est
strictement interdit d'y entrer comme le
test cette belle tête de mort les
galeries ne sont pas ventilé et donc il
y a
probablement des garrigues sont pleines
de méthane qui peut exploser
également il n'y a pas du tout d'oxygène
dans la plupart des galeries donc tu
peux tu étouffes et enfin même temps
dormir sans en rendre compte
ça fait un très bon rappel de les
conditions de travail des mineurs qui
étaient donc c'est un métier très
dangereux
c'est un métier très dangereux parce que
tu peux tomber sur une poche de gaz et
ça explose tout meurt d'un gain dé quoi
je préfère faut faire gaffe dans ce
genre de situation parce que t'es pas
nous avons visité sûr de lui abandonner
c'est hyper dur bosser en hiver dans les
températures abominable entrée sous
terre creusée le parma frost extraire le
charbon sortir il feignit façon et que
tout le tournis en hiver au total 125
mineurs sont morts dans les mines entre
1916 et 2016 aujourd'hui l'aveu par des
mines ont fermé à cause de la chute du
prix du charbon à la fin des années 2000
et celle qui est encore en activité sert
principalement à alimenter la ville de
beaune qui reviennent en chauffage
l'économie locale se tournent désormais
vers le tourisme l'éducation et la
recherche vous montrer à quoi ressemble
une région polaire on est parti explorer
l'île de spitsbergen l'archipel de
svalbard faire environ 61 mille
kilomètres carrés
la température annuelle moyenne est de
moins 5,6 degrés et le thermomètre peut
même descendre jusqu'à moins 20 des
conditions climatiques très hostile qui
font qu'il ya très peu d'espèces
animales dans la région la plus
emblématique d'entre elles étant
évidemment l'ours polaire
même si leur nombre est très difficiles
à recenser il y aurait entre 1100 et
3400 individu es belle barbe
maquillée curieux donc il faut qu'on se
protège c'est un très grand prédateur
dès lors qu'on sort de la vie la police
peut plus assurer notre protection et
donc il faut absolument qu'on s'équipe
d'un fusil et d'un flair gueule je vous
expliquer un peu le principe quoi je les
porte
même si elles sont très rares il y a eu
cinq attaques mortelles d'ours polaires
durant ces quarante dernières années et
les autorités sont extrêmement vigilante
vis-à-vis des règles de sécurité
concernant l'animal donc si on voit un
ours au loin la première chose à faire
c'est de les effrayer
souvent ça suffit sifflé faire du bruit
et s'enfuir surtout si l'on a repéré
qu'ils apporteront intéressés se servira
du flair gun pour tirer soit des
cartouches de détresse rouge uniquement
pour effrayer l'ours soit carrément des
flashs banques qui font une grosse
explosion lumineuses et sonores et
souvent ça suffit pour effrayer l'ours
est est ce que tu sois en moyenne
combien yat d'ours qui sont tués comme
ça pour des sorties de personnes hors de
la ville malheureusement est en train et
deux ours qui sont tués par an
uniquement pour la protection des offres
il faut bien savoir que personne n'a
envie de tuer l'ours malheureusement ici
on a vite sur un de ces territoires
il ya souvent des la banquise qui se
porte dans les fjords donc les phoques
qui viennent s'y reproduire et les ours
viennent manger les phoques donc assez
courant de croiser des ours ici toute
façon les gens ici on ont suffisamment
peur pour éviter l'ourson maximum et moi
je ne croise personne
en dehors de la ville qui n'a pas un
fusil voilà le fusil est admis chargé
souriez rien de trouvé un cadavre de
rennes
très très très dispersé
mais rennes ici n'ont pas de prédateurs
ils ont du mal à trouver de la
nourriture l'hiver quand ils deviennent
trop vieux à force de chercher l'air
beau milieu du rocher faire appel ils
usent leurs dents qu'ils ne repoussent
pas comme le rongeur du coup ils
finissent par ne plus arriver à se
nourrir quand ils sont trop vieux et il
est donc là ils vont se faire
probablement mangé par les renards
polaires
donc ça faut pas toucher il ya des virus
qui se baladent et des trucs qu'on n'a
pas trop envie d'avoir notamment la rage
bon là ça va commencer est un peu raide
jusqu'au plateau
c'est le printemps tant les oiseaux nous
en hiver on n'entendait rien
j'avais lagopède rennes renard et ours
pire rien d'autre choix que d'annoncer
cha très simple de reconnaître ses
frasques que tapie quatre animaux dans
le coin c'est le désert
un désert alors que les eaux sont hyper
riche territoire est complètement vide
tu comprends que celle où j'ai comme un
mammifère marin
c'est lui et il a raison c'est la
richesse mais n'arrive
une stèle en mémoire de celle qui s'est
fait manger par un ours ici fait partie
des rares accidents ces dernières années
ils étaient deux femmes qui étaient
montés son plateau et l avion aurait
aucun fusil aucun sérieux
donc ça c'est la triste conséquence de
quoi on sait qu'il a commis trop ça
passe ça parce qu'un jour ça casse
voilà
[Musique]
elle égale à 20
on a impressionné de voir que ça peut
être aussi oscille encore là on a la
chance on a une période où c'est pas le
plus froid mais deux minutes on peut
avoir les doigts mais complètement rio
riffier il peut arriver que quand on
fait pas gaffe physiquement c'est les
engelures donc bout des doigts bout des
pieds vous fait d'être chaque
régulièrement faux les faux les bouger
très régulièrement et si la situation
dégénère on peut passer le genre dans
jure ça c'est pas quelque chose qui va
se résorber en quelques mois il ya
vraiment un risque que ce soit vis et
qui s'amène même parfois des amputations
on essaye souvent de comparer avec un
désert de sable ou la jungle pour savoir
si c'est un milieu dans lesquels on
pourrait survivre juste quelques
semaines voire quelques jours et avec
ici y'a rien qui pousse n'ya pas
d'alimentation ya pas d'abri fonds ne
tiendrait vraiment vraiment pas
longtemps
depuis les années 70 la températures en
arctique a augmenté de 2 degrés celsius
alors qu'elle a augmenté de 6 degrés
dans le reste du monde
la communauté scientifique a donc les
yeux rivés sur l'archipel car elles
servent de laboratoires pour mieux
comprendre les changements climatiques
mondiaux
une piste vient de lancer une expédition
qui part de l'arctique pour aller en
antarctique pour préserver la
biodiversité des océans et sensibiliser
au sujet du changement climatique ouais
sur l'esperanza y ait un débat est hot
topic
[Musique]
si à minimath
selon un rapport de l'agencé
environnementale norvégienne qui a été
publié en 2019
les températures à svalbard pourrait
augmenter de 7 à 10 degrés d'ici 2100
[Musique]
j'aime faire pression sur les
gouvernements parce que des négociations
ont lieu cette année à new york et
l'année prochaine en de l'île or pour la
signature d'un traité sur la potm r
l'objectif est d'obtenir la création
d'un vaste réseau d'aires marines
protégées qui pourrait couvrir jusqu'à
30% de la surface des eaux
internationales
les enjeux de ce traité sont très
importants et représente un espoir
énorme pour la communauté scientifique
et les associations environnementales
[Musique]
oh
les modèles climatiques qui sont
utilisés par les scientifiques prédisent
que la fonte de la banquise va se
poursuivre au cours des prochaines
décennies et que celle ci pourrait même
disparaître à l'été 2000 40
c'est quand même fou de se dire que la
puissance quelque part qu'on a acquis et
démesurée au point de pouvoir effacer
d'ici quelques décennies ces paysages là
où en fait il ya pratiquement aucun
humain c'est très triste de se dire
qu'un jour peut-être pas ici ce sera
d'une canne et de la mousse des cas il y
aura plus cette beauté sauvage lui qu'on
sera dans quelque chose de tempérer
poignet
[Musique]